les maisons de disques françaises ne
sont pas très nombreuses et certaines
connaissent des difficultés quand il
s'agit de la vente de disques classiques
ces difficultés sont quelques points
sérieuse sans vouloir faire de publicité
pour quiconque on peut dire que des
firmes comme hadès à riom où harmonium
monde y font un travail courageux à
preuve de qualités mais qu'elles sont
souvent plus riche d'espoirs que de
moyens aussi l'on peut peut-être marquer
de la satisfaction en assistante au
mariage de l'une de ces maisons et
râteau avec gaumont la grande société de
production cinématographique qui entre
ainsi dans le monde du disque je vous
invite à suivre maintenant une enquête
sur ce mariage menée par you back
grégoire
a marché a beaucoup marché
pierre boulez dirige d'histoire du
soldat de stravinsky avec l'ensemble
intercontemporain et les comédiens
patrice chéreau antoine vitez et roger
planchon beaucoup parfaire cet événement
musical sans registre en ce moment pour
erato firme française que dirige avec
minutie d'armor jean michel garcin alors
monsieur planchon vous êtes en forme ça
a l'air d'aller pas bien bon ben on peut
recommencer peut-être 1
le temps que j'ai pu par exemple en
angleterre et aux états unis de
travailler
naturellement pour des firmes pour une
firme qui était nettement anglo saxon
disant américaine est là avec un râteau
naturellement c'est un domaine qui est
plus spécifiquement dix ans au départ
nationale mais ce qui n'empêche pas
étant donné la structure dans tout ce
mandat voire une division mondiale ce
qui est intéressant tout de même on ne
peut pas se cantonner seulement faire
des discours un seul pays et il faut
être assuré de la diffusion en général
et je crois que dans ce cas là on a
réuni si vous voulez le surplace et la
diffusion aujourd'hui pierre boulez mais
ira tôt c'était déjà le trompettiste
maurice andré le flûtiste jean qui prend
pas c'était aussi le tdm de chantier
devenu l'indicatif de l'eurovision
actuellement erato vend chaque année
deux millions cinq cent mille disques
près des deux tiers à l'étranger c'est
pour la france la troisième firme de
musique classique
malgré cela et malgré 25 % des actions
vendues aux amériques à la maison manqué
de disponibilité pour se maintenir et se
développer la société gaumont en
rachetant erato votants faire la rivale
des plus grandes élargir le catalogue et
exporter davantage
il est évident que l'art comme disait
malraux est aussi une industrie
je trouve qu avait en france une une
carence au niveau industriel et que
quand j'ai su qu'une maison comme erato
aussi importante dans son histoire par
son poids se trouvait à prendre j'ai
pensé que l'occasion était là vous savez
on fait des discours a posteriori mais
tout se passait comme herman d'amour les
avais la vie des affaires
mais on dit que vous allez revendre une
certaine partie de vos actions à une
firme américaine
oui le problème est à l'envers à savoir
que cette grande maison américaine avait
depuis déjà quelques années une présence
dans le capital de la société avait
surtout une option sur la société et
qu'il a fallu toute notre énergie et la
compréhension des dirigeants des
sociétés pour accepter de ne pas
racheter et bientôt donc
jetons contraire nous qui avons pu
limiter leur présence qui sera de toute
façon tout à fait minoritaire donc
et avec un avantage que nous très
positif pour nous à savoir que leur
présence de la société va nous
l'espérons donner des possibles des
distributions dans le monde entier qui
seront supérieures à celles d'une
société française qui reste petit ça va
bien pour le moment mais le royaume
n'est pas un bon mariage pour ira tôt
mais d'autres maisons français cherchent
des prétendants ou en tout cas l'aide
que méritent les efforts qu'elles font
pour lé développement de la culture et
ans au prince sont nés vous qu'ils
sachent qu'à présent ma patience est à
bout